hello everyone and welcome to ghostwire
tokyo
i cannot see the logo there we go
um i was going to do a
thank you
a q a for this video but when i took
questions from you guys the questions
were like is it too easy
is it good
and
what is it and so i felt like it would
make more sense to just do the hour-long
gameplay to cover those kinds of
questions because people didn't have a
whole lot of questions so if you didn't
know ghostwater tokyo is i believe an
action adventure made by the same team
uh as
cool
also cool thank you as um
the evil within but it is not a horror
game
and yeah we're gonna play through the
first hour this is my first time playing
hmm
i'm this cool guy
can't use a live one i'm gonna vanish
does that mean
you just possessed a dead person
am i like a demon i have questions
clearly
uh the thing that i'm concerned about
with this game from what we've seen is
the same as like the questions i was
getting asked is that i'm mostly worried
that the combat isn't going to feel fun
the animations look great but
i'm excited to see how the spell casting
actually
feels to play it looks a little bit slow
as my concern so excited to see
is that a phone
sitting
perfectly upright somehow
what what
it's a mirror
[Music]
that's fair bro also he kind of cute
you'll see my face
well like the
black smoke that's coming from my arm
it's very prototypy looking actually
like alex mercer
kind of similar concept now i think
about it
foreign
it's quite an
opening did that just like evaporate his
whole body
trying to see if anything else moves in
that mirror
squad rolls deep
come here
i think we just gonna make friends with
them let's just hang out with them they
look cool as hell they look way cooler
than those other nerds
a lot more story than i was expecting
for some reason it's not that different
to the way that the evil within has
always started we do go story heavy
he looks cool
okay he's talking to the soul things
everybody who's dead
this is some death stranding [ __ ]
what
that's [ __ ] up
damn he's super cute yeah
look at the big one
okay
wait so i'm not the thing that has
possessed me is not one of
them
cyberpunk
[Music]
foreign
forbidden west you're updating
it's like fight club
oh my god
am i gonna have to like fight myself
throughout this game
the veins on his hands that's cool
all right
let's go
what could go wrong
i love the rain on the jilsons it's so
good it always feels so good
why'd you even have me walk then
i hate that when you get a little bit of
gameplay and then another cutscene tries
me nuts
come back
okay
assisted aiming
oh interesting
okay that doesn't feel great so far but
it's just one
it's just one attack i guess it's like
sort of like shooting very slow
gun i guess
not much
i think if i go into it it's going to
kill me right i just want to see
oh i just won't even let me go into it
that's interesting okay
these reflections be looking good also
this really does look like tokyo
it really really does
this is like
a million streets around shibuya
that's super cool
oh he just said shibuya look at me go
i've been there
i am already sprinting but thank you
jumped right ahead of you there
okay
she's totally not gonna be in there the
whole game's gonna be about trying to
find her
oh oh
you wanted me to do oh you can manually
sorry you can milly
other and crystallize ellie will come
across crystallized other that can be
destroyed with either ethereal weaving
obviously or strike attacks are three
doing so will shatter the deposit
release the sheriff ether i guess it's
supposed to be called ether
absorbing ether stores sp the energy
used to okay
there's no impact which is a bummer
um okay
let's go
can i punch this
it is the system
timing is the same in english and
japanese is that what i just heard
anxious message takum come back right
away there's white smoke coming from the
entrance it might be poison
so yeah so far
this isn't scary at all but i couldn't
tell you why i would expect a hospital
like coming into a hospital early in a
game made by this team to be spooky but
it's not spooky
maybe it will get maybe i'm speaking too
soon
i am interested in what's going on
i think the
thing with this game will be whether the
gameplay is enough to hold me over and i
just don't know yet
foreign
i suppose there is okay
that was pretty cool i like that maybe
it'll be yeah maybe it'll be a bit more
stealthy than i expected
i leveled up okay
max hp has increased synergy level
okay
okay
gaining a synergy level grants you
spirit skill points you can check your
current skill points and spend them in
the skills menu note that the block
parts are various spirit skill trees
require magatama
to unlock
okay
one
is that this
this
charge attack interesting okay
was everything else wind weaving
what does that look like
oh that's what i already have so this is
just a charged version of the wind
weaving
it's gonna be oh that's a shame i wish i
could see them so this is water and this
is fire obviously
hmm
don't worry mom i'm in the hospital now
i think i'll be okay oh you hate to see
it you hate to see it
oh life comes out you've asked okay
all right
just trying to find my sister oh
you're gonna do spooky stuff
oh sorry charge it the hallway apologies
that was cool
they're hot
shopping bags
it's like health or something
yeah okay i think i still have full
health i do okay
i think they're noisier than they are
scary but he he does seem to be hearing
me
i don't think i can sneak up behind this
dude
it is just him right
a lot of noise man
let's try it let's try it this is just
one
she's just on a pc over there huh
good day sir
that was silent surely right yeah you
didn't hear that completely silent don't
worry about it
what you doing looking at hot girl stuff
porn
no
it's different for her because she
doesn't have a head i'm sorry i did the
head snap animation when ui headless is
very sensitive of me
i apologize for that
hastily written log another prank i got
a nice call from room 403 in the middle
of the night can you check it out can
you be more specific why do you need me
to check it out room 403 is empty the
patient passed away last week
my
god
that's
terrifying
all right i hear you i hear you
missing person fly we are seeking
information about the following incident
a girl in this photograph disappeared on
april 15 last sighted shopping at
429 in shibuya if you have any
information regarding our whereabouts
please call immediately
please call immediately
all right i hear you
i hear you being scary doing hot girl
[ __ ] out here
i'm right okay
everybody pipe down
i mean let's just kill him i don't think
i need to be pretty about it right
i thought that maybe i could grab their
cause when they go oh uh block
i missed it okay again
yeah it's definitely too slow to feel
particularly fun just yet but i know you
get more abilities so
i think maybe if i get like
if this one's like ranged and then
there's like a shotgun type thing or
something like that um
i can see that working out
we just don't have those sensibilities
quite yet okay
can't go through here
i can go through there
i pressed x to try to open it and make
me jump my bad my bad my bad
something about the side to side frame
rate is uh
it's a bit rough
now to hospital director when i found
out in the operating room before he died
he kept muttering about how he could see
some woman then i saw her myself it was
a terrifying sight to behold she was
like some kind of shadow and she looked
like she was wearing a mask
please you need to lock that or i've
seen the shadow so many times since that
day and i know i'm not the only one the
room needs to be locked up before the
patients start talking
again definitely horror themes but i
think it's so bright that i'm not scared
maybe
but that can't be good there's no
there's no way this isn't gonna be a
flickering light or some [ __ ] in here
there's no way this room is chill
i knew it and it still scared me i knew
it was gonna do it it
[ __ ] scared the [ __ ] out of
god damn me
you're not allowed to scare me when i
when i call it that's not fair
oh man
that's rude that's really rude
okay
doesn't count as scary okay i'm still
not classifying this as a horror game
visual glitches uh
they're just sudden
okay
see i'm not scared of that show your
face
that's just convenient you cleared the
way
i feel like my heart is beating much
faster now though
it's just visual it's fine
mari
no so [ __ ] change notes
toshiyuki
patient room transfer 403 to 402 noise
complaint for adjacent room low water
pressure flowers came from brother needs
paws
sister
you're you're on fire just stay there
let me get you it uh
give it one of those fire retardant a
blankets
she just that scampi sister of mine just
keeps getting away
you know what are you gonna do just
watch your sister bernadette i guess
i'm the one who brought the flowers look
at me god
what a good boy
top 10 brothers in anime
oh
that's very evil within a view certainly
also sort of death stranding
my sister has touched the other side
i'm her brother
dude he looks so cool i just let him win
it's the most stylish thing i've ever
[ __ ] seen
he's just a regular looking guy
yeah he looks much less cool than i
thought he would
that is underwhelming
um
oh cool
well that's all right then that's great
whoa i knew he was cooler than me what
did i say
there's a bunch of them
damn
again
oddly death stranding
what
what
um
we'll be fine right
it's a scratch
yeah no we'll be fine we'll be fine
time to go home pack it up
she seems good
we're fine nobody just penetrated our
chest
completely fine
again it's definite
why don't you have a cool mask dude
[Music]
you
wow gentlemen
[Music]
it looks kind of nice here is this
heaven
canonically
it seems so bad
okay
so now we're working together
feel the flowers big ocean
got it i'm up to speed on everything
that's happening i understand
now
the end the good demon
who controls my body are in cahoots
cool
my face is less holy
that's good
what happened to my chest
marie
we've all been there we've all been
there
relatable yeah
i wonder if she's the key to this
somehow then what is going on
oh you locked her in and there was a
fire
oh brother
[Applause]
oh that's not good you shouldn't you
shouldn't do that
yeah
that'll get your sister wound up in the
hospital my friend
all right
i kind of like kk even if he doesn't
look cool which is devastating
the veins look cool
are we just going to rehash this
conflict that i thought we just resolved
yeah i agree with kk
technically i'm the one that's in
control of the body
you guys ain't doing [ __ ]
i mean it technically is but i thought
that would actually give me like a
loading screen
i don't know if that was the game trying
to spook me
more phones to read
patient registration code
please present your insurance card
during your first hospital visit of each
month that's not how that works you have
to do it every time
i'm in america baby
no bad guys in here just a bike to punch
it's kind of like control definitely
evil within vibes definitely some death
stranding vibes
but
it is kind of like control so that's the
first mission we probably just finished
ah there's your loading screen
interesting choice
it's quick though
on to chapter two all right let's go
so that took
about half an hour
i wonder how long the game is
i guess i can't really explore the open
world very much because of the oh
did i just walk into it
where
there
um okay
i guess i'm gonna go towards this icon
that looks like fog though right yeah
uh more more enemies in the upper world
i don't know if i can punch one of them
i would like your call please
did they miss it no no i tried oh
i just think that looks cool
so yeah as it sounds right now combat is
not fun
and it is definitely very easy but it's
literally the start of the game
did he die
oh no he didn't
i mean i like the way they're animated
the sounds are creepy
uh i think you'll find i also need to
punch this bike
now we're done
okay
clean story storygate
yeah i think it might have been this
exact gate that was in the gameplay
trailer
potentially
let me move the top of my webcam down a
little bit i didn't realize i've started
yeah i see it just give me a second
i don't know
shrine mainz from ritualistic kagura
dances okay
seems important
there's a dog
there's a dog
where's that dog
there's another bike to punch
i love bike punch simulator pus what are
you walking at buddy
are you okay little guy
what's going on
hey what are you worried about
i wonder if i can free them oh you just
said yes okay
whoa that's new
you get away from my chibi you know
friend
you big jerk
you too
you just break it
i don't care i just want to see if the
dog's okay
uh how
hello
[Music]
find a phone booth you say
punch these pots on my way did i it
sounded like a cash for those
yellow ether crystals as you explore
should be you may occasionally come
across shining yellow e3 crystals
they will award you with valuable mako
and shattered so be sure to take
advantage of them okay i don't know what
it does yet but good to know
another dog
tony friend
hello there hi hi buddy hello
hi
oh
[Music]
all right 10 out of 10 game of the year
it's done that's it the perfect video
game i got a trophy
you're the perfect animal thank you so
much for blessing me with your presence
i really appreciate it
okay
who's ed did i miss something
there's a lot going on
oh great
we just like
teleport them
doesn't seem good seems like maybe that
wasn't supposed to happen
i'm not feeling great about it you guys
oh is this sad no no surely not can't be
this couldn't be it
he's not ned
him
okay let's go
we can do it
hey buddy
hello
hey
oh my god
wow
oh what a great video game
special devices are scattered through
special devices are scattered throughout
shibuya hidden inside ordinary telephone
booths
these are actually machines that
transport the spirits you've absorbed
with katashiro to safety outside the
barrier
a friend of kk is named ed awaits their
arrival and will help them become more
become living humans once more the more
spirits you send the more xp you'll be
rewarded with so try to save as many of
them as you can
gotcha mate
well it's [ __ ] gay
all right this seems like a place
somebody would try to fight me if i'm
being honest
hey cap
my friends no no no
dammit
[Music]
yeah burke is spelled that's cool
[Music]
the amount of sound that they make
actually makes it kind of difficult to
tell how many there are
j suppose makes it more atmospheric but
it could be difficult for
some players with certain disabilities
to get around
why would you let me open the trash if
there's nothing in there
make it make sense
that doesn't make sense come on
head to uh
foreign
uh
that's kind of cool i did it with the
touch pad
i like that that's cool very slow but
i assumed that kk was not of this world
and maybe he is
can i buy any new skills
it's this that i want i disagree i think
i am ready okay what is this stuff then
i'm not ready for anything
increases hp restored i don't feel like
i need that enemy codes exposed speed of
an enemy core extraction oh that seems
like i like that one
uh unless you do directly grab and crush
enemy closet cross range that's cool
ground attack boost
quick purge on down to enemies
i can see that being something i would
like
spirit absorption speed boosts that's
interesting the fact that there are so
many speed boosts means that they've
intentionally started the game slow
and that the ideal way to play probably
is faster because it does
the interactions do feel very slow so
maybe
all of its speed increases
hmm
i think i'm gonna go with this one for
now
okay
magnetic field measurements
oh this is ed
um
busy street crossing in the whole world
can't have gone super well
yeah god is that polly polyamorous
well go us all right
what did i just take another
food from the other side okay i'm super
into this wall that's all i'm saying
listen periodicals need all these asap
inspecting underworld gates encyclopedia
of japanese solstice life and death at
cultural history instant noodle almanac
2020
spectral food fruit from the underworld
not only restores your health like
everyday food but also grants you a
temporary boost your abilities oh that's
cool
well this stuff you'd only have buffs
brown doll said to be model after
buddhist monk that brings good luck when
displayed
um they wouldn't have all these buffs if
they weren't expecting things to be hard
sewer kit a report written by k.k
regarding a number of disappearances
that took place near a manhole
oh
okay side quests
i just got plus 20 skill points
[ __ ]
you still can't unlock anything else
right
shortens time for ethereal weaving
attacks it's all time based that means
they know it's slow
fire rate for wind weaving attacks
increases the number of shots fired for
charge now let's do this one
kk's investigation notes finding them
will grant you spirits go oh okay
uh i think i already looked at that one
okay
japanese batman
because he had a cool bow
it could be a lot worse this is a lot of
a lot of wireless keyboards
a lot of wireless keyboards must get
confusing how do you know which ones
which they're not even labeled
okay
this one
2k put the utensils away throughout the
empty food containers and get the
kitchen cleaned up before i get back you
slope
didn't happen did it didn't happen
that's a good touch that's that's good i
like that
okay
i have a timer
exciting
oh let's just close that give me a
second thank you it was i'm rude he's
supposed to put your toilet seat down
okay
yeah it's definitely more in the realm
of the control brand of of horror
rather than evil within horror like
visual creepiness whoa this is just cool
to me though
oh arrows okay don't need them
uh
i assumed that you want uh
this didn't look like this before
probably shouldn't be wasting as much
time as i am
but uh i like to live life on the edge
so
assuming this is right
i wonder if you can use the bow
effectively in combat
or if that
won't work
it's only for puzzles maybe
come on close your toilets
this is cool
i feel like oh something breathed i feel
like i'll be able to burn through that
at some point that's my guess
i just can't help myself
i just keep interacting with everything
even when i don't need to
okay
punch the vacuum don't mind me
new enemy type oh don't mind if i do
don't mind if i do oh
another closet with nothing in it can't
help myself
why would you do that to me
i'm gonna spend so when you combine the
hours that i've spent opening cupboards
that have nothing in them it's gonna get
nasty
that was that was really cool i think
this game is actually very interesting
um
i don't like the combat right now
i imagine it gets better but i always
hate that as like an excuse um
satisfying immediately you know in a
game like prototype
uh just to
continue that odd and probably not
fitting parallel at least like it gives
you all the powers at the start so you
know what it feels like and then takes
them away so you're like oh well i'll
get to that though this is very slow
right now in terms of combat to the
extent that it's not particularly fun
and yes the enemies are excessively easy
however i think the world and the
aesthetic um
is interesting i like both the
characters
but i'm such a big combat person
unfortunately
spectral
it's like a little bit more detective-y
than i expected to i think because i
guess kk is a detective
kk slider
this is a great representation of
tokyo shibuya i can't go there
oh maybe we can do something with it
what do you mean by that try reaching
out with my power
i expected that to be a lot more
elaborate than it was corruption and
spirit spirits can sometimes be caught
up in unchecked corruption you can use
your spectral vision to uncover the
source of the corruption once you've
destroyed this source and free the
spirits you can absorb them
what's this a cat
the sound is very good
but there there's a cat
foreign
damn
they get real with it all right let's go
the cat
the cat though
read thoughts
you see the bad mood
oh what about now
okay hang on let me i will pet you my
friend however i can
pat
this isn't petting
uh
buddy why why i'm trying to put the cat
in a good mood
hello tiny cat excuse me
i just keep doing this when i'm trying
to pat the cat
can i feed it
i'm sorry i'm sorry buddy it's probably
my allergies
the game knew you know the game knew
what was that going to do about it
is this tell me the store here that i
can actually enter [ __ ] idioms
i don't feel like i need any of this but
wow
oh he likes okay let's get you some
insta noodles then
you like them you you want it you got it
there's dog food but there's no
[Music]
we do
i'm liking the amount of dialogue too
okay let's give another one for dogs but
i can't give anything to that cat
unfortunately
maybe just one more time pat
pat pet pet cat pet pet
it's not happening all right i give up
find a dog that's the next objective
right find dog
give treats
not that i know how to
object
i wonder if the birds signify the torah
gates
what grapple
what
um
that's cool okay
i know i did absolve them hold x in mid
at a glide what the [ __ ]
yeah this is such an interesting game
okay so we're gonna
would not have expected okay who's who's
trying to beef with me
where are you
combat is definitely too easy
again thus far
i'm gonna investigate the laptop first
mine now [ __ ]
recording left behind by certain
scientists discussing family and cats
okay
got it
spirit was something to say oh it wants
me to do them
okay
hmm
what is that's the thing i'm supposed to
jump off right that's [ __ ] allowed
where is it
bro where you flapping oh how do i get
there
there
right maybe we should just jump again
first
japanese calendar encyclopedia entry
three the tenth month in the traditional
japanese lunar calendar around october
the middle character of the kanji for
kanazuki was initially used for its
sound instead of meaning there should be
nothing to write home about except that
while the pronunciation should mean
month of the gods the kanji themselves
read the month without gods my my mind
by the complicating this is the fact
that it is the month the shinto gods are
said to convene at the azuma taisha
shrine
so it can be both interpreted either as
the gods coming together for this month
or as the gods leaving their usual homes
thus making in a month when they are
absent
that's crazy who'd have thought
another rice ball damn
a lot more vertical than i would have
thought to
let's just go down
i would like that piece
i love
[ __ ] up bikes it's my number one
hobby
and picking up plastic bags
those are my two things
hey bud
new enemy new enemy type sia you see her
over there
what's she gonna do oh
interesting
okay not that much turns out
they're very slow
oh
that's not great
i missed
i didn't actually know i could run out
of that so
that'll do it the bow is cooler
uh spectral whatever
red other crystals
oh
that does make sense
um
i'm not seeing it
you told me these would have like hearts
or whatever
where they at
or is it maybe not all of them oh it's
there
i just want to find a dog
before i finish
no i should all right it is late um i
hope you guys enjoyed this and now have
a better understanding of what this game
is i do feel like it's going to open up
a lot more which means i guess my issue
is right now probably with the pacing i
could be wrong maybe the combat doesn't
speed up it just feels like it might um
i'm really interested in the world of
the law yeah don't love the way it feels
to play unfortunately the buzz pretty
cool
i want to i want to play more i want to
check more out so that's my my current
stance um the vibe is interesting yeah
definitely more control action adventure
rather than evil within typhara
so certainly something new for the team
but um hope you guys enjoyed this video
i'll see you next time